hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well
early on in fact at the very beginning
of nikka mechanics book 9 Aristotle is
going to discuss a very interesting
topic and give us a few guidelines about
it and it's something that he's been
touching on quite a bit over the course
of his discussions about friendship in
book 8 and also running through book 9
and it has to do with this notion of
trading or gifts or or exchange and a
friendship there is this element like I
put here it's sort of an integral
component of friendship that there's
some sort of exchange that's taking
place between the people who are
involved in the relationship and this
this runs throughout each of the three
types of friendship that Aris Levin was
talking about friendship in terms of
virtue or or you know the intrinsic
goodness of the people who get to know
each other for their own syncs and who
love each other or not on that basis
they are going to do things for each
other and then you know on the other
extreme we have friendships of
usefulness where clearly the people are
in the friendship because they're
getting something out of the other
person otherwise it doesn't make sense
for them to be in a friendship and then
we have friendship in terms of pleasures
sort of in the middle and
in case it's it's the pleasure that
each's to riding either directly from
the other person or by enjoying things
together but in in company which will
events the the enjoyment they have
brings them together so there's an
element of exchange in all of those
Aristotle says that in unequal
friendships that we've got a video
specifically about them you know we're
perhaps one person is virtuous and the
other person is useful or one person is
useful or the other person is Pleasant
this is going to be a factor as well
there's going to be some sort of giving
and taking in return
and also this will apply to the whole
range of relationships that Aristotle
discusses that we could lump under the
the notion familial relationships right
relationships you can parents and
children spouses cousins siblings all of
those involve some sort of giving and
taking in in return and it's some of the
question that comes up is well what
provides the measure for it and
Aristotle says if we look at economic
exchanges you know like shoemaker and
you know somebody helping to bring those
shoes to market right there there's
going to be some sort of exchange the
shoemaker will come to a bargain that he
can live with the porter will come to a
bargain that he can live with and they
will swap things back to earth goods and
services right so in a friendship it's
not going to be money although that
functions as the medium of exchange for
economic transactions so what would be I
mean we could say as we have in other
discussions that it's affection it's the
feeling of friendship towards the other
person you know Marysol says an unequal
friendships the person who is served on
the lower end or who is perhaps not as
useful not as pleasurable not as
virtuous as the other person they can
make up for it by providing the only
other thing that they have left which is
greater affection for the other person
or perhaps greater on or even too
person that that's something that can
equalize the exchange but at a certain
point people want to know what am I
actually getting out of this to make it
fair and so Aristotle is going to ask
this question what is what is going to
work this way with friends
what will provide the equalization of
value you might say and so a lot of this
you talks about any examples where
people get upset with each other and get
an arguments about this for example is
because it's translated here sentimental
friendships it was really erotic
relationships the the lover and the
beloved it may make complaints as the
lovers sometimes complain that his
warmest affection beats with no
affection in return and it may be
because there's nothing in him to arouse
affection the person a lot of frequently
complaints that the lover of performers
formerly promised everything now
fulfills none of his promises and this
is sort of a a exaggerated limit point I
mean that does happen in some cases but
there there's quite a few instances like
that in a romantic or erotic
relationships where people are going to
be saying look you you're just not
giving me what it is that I want out of
this I'm giving you what it is that you
want
where's my heart right and we can say
this about business relationships we can
say this about sports teams you know
where people and I pass the ball to you
how come you never reciprocate you never
pass the ball back to me you just want
to be the one to score the goal all the
time or get the basket whatever and we
can go on and on and on with with
examples like this so a hero stumble
says it's very important to attend to
what is being exchanged and what value
it has because people are going to
differ over how these these things
should be evaluated some people say look
I gave you what it is that I thought you
wanted or what
anybody reasonable person would want or
what you said you wanted in the first
place why aren't you happy why are you
complaining right
and so aerosol gives us some some useful
guidelines here he divides things up
into several different kinds of cases so
for example in a friendship that's based
on virtue where you are involved with
the friend on the basis of who they are
this requires that they have good moral
character in order so it's a you know
finding that part of them attractive and
to appreciate it yeah but let's say
that's that's there that would be the
paradigm case of this this first
instance when a gift or the service is
given for the sake of the receiver a
virtuous person is going to act not in
order to get something back out of it
because that's not actually virtuous
they're doing it because they are
they're prone to be generous they are
prone to be courageous you know stand up
for their friend they are prone to be
just to give their friend the right
measure they are prone to be witty to
the right degree they are prone and we
can go on and on and on right when the
gift of the service is given for the
sake of the fret and not in order to get
something out of it then who decides
what the value of it is it's not just
the person who's receiving it in that
case Aristotle says it's actually the
intention of the giver that determines
its value it could be in part because
the friend doesn't actually realize what
a great gift they are getting from the
other person you know when we talk about
unequal friendships in terms of virtue
the virtuous person acting in relation
to the friend who is friends with with
them because they admire the virtue of
that person has but the friend who is
only you know pleasant or useful or
perhaps it's just a family member and
it's neither pleasant or useful in those
sorts of cases the person who is
receiving the gift the service of the
benefit may not actually realize what it
cost or what the extent of it is or how
valuable it really is
they may you might say is we use the
expression take it for granted taking
something for granted involves a sort of
blindness to the genuine value of what
is being provided and also as
contingency the fact that it doesn't
have to be that way you know we're
talking about people sometimes having a
sense of entitlement you know this is a
safeguard against that ear assault let's
say it's in this sort of case where
you're not expecting anything in return
should there be anything given in return
it's the person who gave originally who
gets to say that's not a sufficient you
know response or well you know that's
nice that you did that but it's nothing
like what I gave you the other person
doesn't get to respond and say oh
whether they're completely equal right
and we could extend this into all sorts
of other things as well I think family
relationships are a lot like this you
know relationship parents and children
it's not a child who gets to decide
unless the parent is explicitly trying
to get something out of it the parent is
being a good parent and doing things for
the benefit of the kids and not
expecting anything or too much or
anything even remotely like it in return
it's the parent who gets to decide how
valuable that that was now in other
cases when there is an expectation of
giving so that you get something back
reciprocation if not complete
reciprocity then who gets to decide it's
not the giver in that case it's either
both parties work it out together or if
they can't work it out the tiebreaker
gets to be the person who receives the
benefit this is a really great idea
because this precludes people giving
things to other people and then saying
oh hey I gave you that and that's
valuable to me so it should of course be
equally valuable to you so you need to
give me something in return the the
receiver could say I didn't
ask you for what you gave me as a matter
of fact your gift came with too many
conditions too many strings I don't want
it why are you giving this to me or they
can say you know you gave it to me but
it came at the wrong time it wasn't
helpful when you gave it to me or it was
too early or you know it wasn't the kind
that I needed you know we can think
about all sorts of ramifications of this
in terms of the gift-giving that goes on
during the holiday season and you know
the fact that people sometimes get a
little bit upset when they see somebody
exchanging the gift right why does
somebody exchange a gift well I could
because they're you know really hard up
for money and they know honey in which
case you know is there a really they
have heard help and you're their friend
you probably want to help them out but
it could be because you gave them a gift
that they simply don't want they've
already got a duplicate of it or they
don't think that it's it's it's
something that suits them it's something
that you like but they aren't really
interested in so Aristotle says that it
is the person who receives who gets to
determine the value of what it is that
they receive we might also think about
re-gifting in this manner right some
things there's like greed gifting that
goes on like an entire chain almost like
these chains of that you know these
necklaces and the South Seas that would
circulate around Marcel Mauss ranks
about in the book the gift sometimes
like that hats things like that
Applewood Secret Santa or in families
but in any case that that's the the
criteria here the receiver gets to
decide what counts as a valuable gift or
not and they get to decide what you know
they should reciprocate with what would
be an equal value now Aristotle does he
have one proviso in here that is
extremely important when that decision
is made about the value of the gift you
don't get to make it after you've
already consumed the gift or you've had
you know for a while somebody gets you a
shirt you don't get to you know decide
what the value of that shirt is 10
months later on you have to decide based
on when you received it or when you made
use of it right so if somebody gets me a
tie
right and the men's ties take a long
time to go get it out of fashion but
presumably this tie is not going to be
in fashion you know 40 years from now or
maybe it'll be retro and it will be back
in fashion you remember back in
seventies it was super wide ties with a
lot of patterns in the 80s it was those
skinny ties you know you know things
okay even guys hang these and after that
if I later on and say to somebody who's
got me this time you know 10 years from
now
hey the timing gave me really it wasn't
any good because look it's out of
fashion now that's an illegitimate thing
on my part similarly somebody gets me a
box of chocolates and at the time that I
get the chocolates I'm very happy about
it because I'm anticipating the taste of
the chocolates and you know how much
enjoyment I'm going to get out of it now
I sit there that gobble them all up
right and then afterwards I get my
stomach hurts and like all those
chocolates were not a good thing I'm not
giving you anything in response Arizona
would say no that's not the way that you
should be decided you decide on the the
you know the way in which you evaluated
before you were intemperate and eating a
host chocolates and so we could go on
and on with that I mean you know rotten
relationships provide a great example of
this what people value you know goods
and services the things that are going
to be exchanged and that is very
different at one time compared to
sometimes even just half an hour later
and Arizona would say well that's not
fair to the other person you have to be
fair and how do you value things so
these are the criteria that Aristotle
gives but I think that if we were indeed
to follow these quite a few of the
disputes that typically arise in the
course of French
chips would probably be smooth out
because this is a very good practical
reason